peu
extrait du dernier rapport du conseil
économique et social sur les
travailleurs étrangers
les estimations les plus courantes
indique qu'une présence étrangère
globale en france aux derniers sondages
d'environ 3 millions 100 mille personnes
l'accroissement du groupe des étrangers
est de l'ordre de 7% par an soit dix
fois le rythme de la croissance de la
population de souche française il est
admis en principe que les travailleurs
étrangers doivent jouir des mêmes droits
que les français sous quelques réserves
fin de citation en camargue quelque part
près d'arles un village de 200 habitants
mas thibert où il ya sept ans pour des
raisons autres que la pure recherche de
travail sont arrivés avec leurs familles
800 à 0
aujourd'hui français musulmans car ils
ont choisi la nationalité française
cette et des arcs les avaient suivi leur
leader le machacka boualem ils se sont
installés à la lisière du village avec
leurs coutumes leurs habitudes leurs
traditions
les activités des harkis pendant la
guerre d'algérie et leur nécessaire
installation en france ensuite ancré en
fait un double problème d'adaptation
aujourd'hui la guerre d'algérie est en
principe oublier les enfants vont à
l'école les jeunes essaient de
travailler
quant aux anciens eux ils essayent de
subsister autour du bassin s'est passé
avec la population s'est très bien passé
il ya eu un petit mot aux français c'est
à dire par exemple raconté les gens
d'origine italienne ou espagnole le
nouveau français est ce qu'il ya eu des
accrochages des bagarres il ya une seule
fois alors on a formulé donc des
reproches fou aux harkis sont là le
projet venus ici d'envahir le village
bien entendu nous étions mal vu les
français musulmans donc ils sont
installés là cancer ou leurs coutumes
les femmes ne sortent pas et c'est nos
femmes bienvenue chez qui ont un certain
âge il est inutile de faire quelque
chose car elle ne voudront bien faire
et croyez-vous que une intégration
possible quand même elle est possible la
preuve c'est qu'ils vont à l'école c'est
le camp 16 et 18 ans vont encore à
l'école
donc je pense que l'intégration est
possible et elle se fera ou non à
l'école mais ne sortent pas
j'estime que c'est un bien car nos
jeunes nos jeunes enfants échappent aux
défis n'ont pas encore l'esprit assez
mûrs pourquoi sortir seul et il ya trop
de tentations pour les jeunes
nous attendons une certaine rigueur mort
cette rigueur morale journal j'en suis
partisan et vous ne croyez pas que ce
puisse être un frein à l'évolution des
jeunes qui s'installent
non ce n'est pas un frein à l'évolution
des jeunes qui s'installent je pense que
dans huit générations une aura plus rien
à envier aux jeunes ainsi de france
frédéric 16 ans fille de arctic sea
frères et soeurs elle porte un prénom
français parce qu'elle a choisi
elle-même à 14 ans de se faire baptiser
pour mieux se mêler du teil à la
population française échapper à son
vieux synthés elle est ce que vous ferez
planté par exemple facilement de jeunes
européens
oui et comment ça se passe vous avez vu
les rapports amicaux normaux gentil ou
bien est ce clair ils vous font sentir
que vous êtes d'origine musulmane qui
sont gentils sympathique toujours
qu'elle faisait mais vos parents par
exemple s'il savait que vous fréquentiez
régulièrement à
jeunes européens quel serait alors le
réaction je crois qu'ils seront pas
d'accord
pourquoi elles vont enfin savoir
c'est à dire qu'il fallait je fais comme
je continue à faire notre région par
exemple se marier avec un art à tous
ceux qui voudraient oui vous ne voulez
pas non mais vous savez que votre père
peut en principe nous obliger à l'épousé
alarme
oui et c'est par exemple ça se passe
quelle serait votre réaction
je serais pas d'accord mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez
parce que vous partiriez de chez vous
est ce que vous iriez ailleurs en fait
qu'est-ce que votre votre position en
soient d'accord pour le mariage mais
votre père alors qu'est-ce qui dirait
écouter qu'est ce que vous pensez
justement de 2,7 obligations qu'ont
parfois les jeunes filles musulmanes
d'obéir à leurs pairs et dé prendre
leurs maris qui leur est imposé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous de
cela je trouve que c'est pas bien parce
que elle connaît même pas le gel et s'il
n'oublie pas mais je trouve que la vie
pour aller seront très différents
frédéric tout en travaillant au chan a
décidé d'étudier ces jeunes français
sont en cours avec elle avec le times
ont canal finir par s'y intégrer et même
la population française si elle a
quelques indices à ce petit peuple qui a
fini par accepter
c'est à dire que les gens vont finir
quand même pas parler considérés comme
des gens comme nous justement quand il
ya un problème d'éducation et de
l'éducation ils doivent parvenir à se
considérer normalement et les contacts
sont naturels avec jeunes européens est
assez probable pour faire pour vous
cette solution oui vous êtes d'accord
assez réservé justement parce qu'elles
ont honte
je vois par exemple quand elle
elles nous font des rédactions où il est
question de description de la maison etc
elles prennent toujours un endroit
extrêmement moderne avec des meubles
dernier cri enfin elles ont tendance à
vouloir copier les les européennes dans
le tout au moins une famille européenne
dans tout ce qu'elle a comme confort et
comme oui comme organisation de vie à la
française
les comptes de ski a chez elle et moi
j'ai vérifié la véracité de leur dire si
vous voulez en allant chez elle et je me
suis rendu compte que des meubles
il y en a très peu que ces misérables
elle rêve d'une promotion et l la
concrétise par un intérieur moderne
français je sais ça le jeudi
samedi après midi le dimanche matin et
au fait ça pour quoi
pour cela me plaît j'aime travailler aux
champs
j'aime être avec des ouvriers qui ont me
largue cet argent qu'est ce que vous en
faites
je les donne à mes parents et ils
puissent y pour continuer mes études
aussi si vous prenez l'exemple du
clochard modique ou non
bon et de l'argent non parfois voulait
pas toujours alors que les chômeurs
annie alors cherche du travail bien sûr
mais en ce moment bateau que les petites
qui sont en commerces et petites harkis
sont les meilleurs de la classe parce
que elles sont très travailleuse très
volontaire en vue d'arriver à qui on a
envie d'arriver à quelque chose alors
que les autres s'endorment
lorsque vous aurez terminer vos études
que comptez vous faire je compte partir
d'ici tout de suite oui pour lui
par un autre vers le nord c'est à dire
c'est à dire puis les comparait ouvert
les alliances dans les environs paris
vous connaissez paris racing va avec
c'est très difficile où parfois la vie à
paris ça fait rien oui voulait échapper
à la vie que vous avez ici
oui qu'est ce qui vous déplaît ce que
c'est un environnement c'est la région
sont les gens non sans les gens je
trouve qu'ils sont racistes
non mais et savez vous aussi dans
d'autres régions par exemple à paris les
gens ne sont pas éventuellement un peu
raciste loaded
je trouve que les gens du nord est déjà
mythique ici pourquoi vous avez vu oui
pendant les vacances vous avez vu des
gens arriver et que comptez-vous faire
exactement quel quel genre de métiers
comptables vous pensez pouvoir trouver
du travail facilement
je ne sais rien j'ai très peur pour elle
parce que par exemple je suis allé chez
un employeur en lui disant j'ai une
sténodactylo qui est extrêmement rapide
afin qu est très très bonne
quand il a vu que c'était une petite
arabe il m'a dit je regrette mais contre
un deuxième je peux employer une arabe
je préfère donner du travail à une
française il y a une espèce de
racisme larvé alors on vous dit elle a
pris la racaille en employer ce mot
suite du rapport du conseil économique
les besoins de logement des migrants et
leurs familles sont très importants si
l'égalité d'accès aux hlm avec des
français est théoriquement reconnu aux
travailleurs étrangers les
discriminations d'honneur dans la
pratique
[Musique]
les critiques actuelles c'est que ces
gens-là ne peuvent pas s'assimiler comme
il devrait le faire puisque nous leur
tendant la perche constamment pour
pouvoir s'assimile à loup mais ils
vivent toujours que dans l'eure dans
leur milieu
et qu'est ce que vous appelez vous
l'assimilation l'assimilation c'est à
dire que de prendre un petit peu nos
habitudes nous avons voulu les initiés
dans dans nos associations
principalement dans le chai au comité du
haut comité de l'amicale
l'amicale de la cité natale de fonds
vers ben les vérités réticences de leur
part mais c'est de réticence manifeste
il viendra qui vient port réunion
quand il ya des andes réunion que nous
avons eue le maximum que nous avons vus
comme indigènes
c était peut-être huit à dix jours mais
en question sur le cieux pourquoi
employer vous le mot indigènes on
emploie le mot indigènes le jeu parce
que ça sonne
nous avons l'habitude que les apps et
indigènes nous étions comment ça se
passe entre les enfants
il se mélange avec les
les petits européens mais la fin est ce
que ça vous le trouver dommage parce que
vous l'appréciez comment est ce que vous
trouvez dommage que les petits algériens
fréquentent le zoo européen ou quoi oui
parce que vous savez il est certainement
certains certaines sont pas ils sont pas
fréquentables
qu'est ce qui vous gêne par exemple dans
l'immeuble que vous habitez au logis
rien ne me gêne et du tout parce que le
généralement le français reste reste
chez lui il ne fréquente pas ces gens là
une rue de montreuil près de paris
sept personnes dans chaque pièce il
reste toujours attaché à leur milieu et
j'ai vite un petit peu leur contact
alors qu'ils n'ont jamais eu un site
pareil dans leur pays vous ne croyez
vous pas qu'il y ait une sorte de
complexe comme vis-à-vis des français
que c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il ne
fera au japon a complexifié le copain de
sa vie les français d'ailleurs je ne
peux pas dire ce que je pense exactement
pourquoi des bleus non ça serait aller à
l'encontre de des buts que nous
recherchons une discussion dans un
centre de formation féminine étrangères
entre deux leçons
ce qui se passe à wall caisson couleurs
de courir il faut vraiment la bienvenue
moi je pense que c'est un amérique on va
dire que ce soit des gens racistes quand
vous êtes noir vous allez en amérique
vous faites attention au 2 mai en france
ce sont des gens soit disant pas raciste
et au contraire qu'ils sont des fois
très raciste seulement et ad je ne sais
pas quoi il faut faire attention vous
par ce rentrer dans les détails mais il
y en a qui serait raciste est pour vous
montrer l'exemple de raciste il ya un
jour dans le métro en face de moi y
avait une bande printemps bien habillé
j'arrive
elle avait son sacre alors c est
demandée racer parce que j'étais un peu
fatigué et bien cette dame a été génial
regarder d'abord bio le pied et puis
elle m'a dit mais vous sortez de chez
vous pour venir demander mais tout
l'argent que vous donne qu'est ce que
vous en faites ne connaissez pas
peut-être gérer demandé aux européens de
venir les colonisés chez moi que nous
allons chercher très en verve au bas des
capitaux y revenir chez doivent se
débrouiller tout seul et que la sortie
507 je me suis assise elle s'est levée
elle a été plus loin mais la batterie de
places assises et restent élevés et puis
moi je pense aussi que les français ne
soient bien pour cesser le 26 parce que
quelquefois dans les prés rencontré un
petit français avec sa môman
il vous touche et puis nous voici ça
mais normalement on dira que sa maman ne
donne une petite correction m
d'où vient le lait ce qui fait d'eux les
enfants ils grandissent avec cette
motion la et sur les plombs logement par
exemple ce que vous avez eu des
problèmes d'habitat fontenay-le-fleury
et je suis obligé de venir ici tous les
jours j'ai cherché un logement partout
mais je n'arrive pas à trouver quelque
chose à chaque fois qu'on dit de venise
quand mon mari l'a oublié le gars est un
noir pour lui c'est déjà les émotions il
est obligé de repartir
m6 qui arrivent il dit [ __ ] des gages
qui est ce moi le futur ça aussi j'ai
passé je n'ai rien dit puisque je suis
dans leur pays avec la plupart du temps
je ne parle pas parce que j'espère qu'on
le fera venir que les jeunes se
rassemblent autour de moi ici je passe
mon vraiment c'est vraiment du racisme à
marseille l'une des meilleure
organisation du genre en france
l'association du travail aux outre-mer
essaie par tous les moyens de former
d'éduquer puis d'intégrer lentement des
étrangers en les mêlant dans les
ensembles aux locataires français
bon
c'est ce que vous pourrez tenter les
femmes algériennes qui se trouve dans
votre immeuble lorsque vous lancez à
venir ceci moi il me manque quelque
chose je vis du mal à me le prêter
volontiers ça se passe pour moi c'est
assez
non non non vraiment pas chacun chez soi
et le rapport du conseil économique et
social signale que 92% de la population
des bidonvilles sont d'origine étrangère
[Musique]
bezombes en soit si par exemple j'ai eu
il m'est arrivé une catastrophe on est
venu s'il y en a ce sont venus ils m'ont
bien rendu service mais après c'est fini
chacun chez soi
[Musique]
oui on peut pas discuter avec des femmes
algériennes comme on discute avec les
femmes françaises fessenheim est
possible la fin du t1 comprenait pas le
policier
et quand vous leur parlez il ay comme
paneriai ils savent pas et il parle dans
le vide vous ne respectiez quelque chose
pourquoi c'est beaucoup à faire et ça
vaut rien il en a pas parlé
leur expliquer comment vivent les
français et non pas les mêmes opinions
sur tout le la discuter d'une chose est
noble et le maillot millions que nous
sommes bien à sa maison quand même à la
reynerie quel guerrier il y en a qui
vivent quand même bien qu'ils vivent
comme les français mais qui va le
défendre c'est faire chacun a sa maison
les étrangers ni le rappeur expédie
chaque année 2 milliards de francs dans
leur fuite
là
je devrais pas d'inconvénient à ce que
ma fille sont à meknes fille algérienne
vous savez on a les filles françaises
qui est avec l'algérien à miami mais en
arriver jusque là mais non la liesse de
pareilles est assez de friendfeed pour
se marier riche histoire
personne ne se cache que l'installation
des travailleurs étrangers en france
pose de multiples problèmes revient de
voir et qu'il faut donc éliminer les
ghettos ethniques dans lesquelles ils
s'enferment tout sauf un an ferme
première solution l'école l'école
classique de mas thibert tout ce passe
bien car les enfants ne connaissent pas
encore le racisme et pour l'enseignement
rapide du français on utilise maintenant
le système audiovisuel comme dans les
cours crédit de l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est tombé mardi sous toit
je sais ce qui arrive aux est tombé
qu'est ce qui arrive est ce qu'elle
avale nous oui elle a mal celui des
sélectionnés que vous êtes a pas mal une
parfaite alors qui est ce que laval
joseph louis où un tel mal ou aux mains
rouges
tu sors tu répètes josette ont un mal à
main aux mains rouges genou et montre
moi tes genoux oui mais toi toi oui mais
mes genoux parfait aller voilà un va et
vient
qu'est-ce que tu habites loin de l'école
c'est nous qui ne sommes pas 68 5 grammy
pour passer mon temps à lui dans
certaines usines
les membres des comités d'entreprise eux
mêmes donnent après le travail des
leçons jours c'est à leur camarade s'est
rangé aux dons
on va répéter les mots qu'on a déjà vu
vo et autour qu'est ce que tu as là
dessus chausseur chaussures je disais
alors on prend la chaussure et on la met
dans la case
dans les usines les rapports entre
étrangers et français sont en général
assez bon les problèmes ne sont pas à ce
niveau dans les grandes villes
généralement on les paye au même prix
quand ceux ci ont une profession assez
qualifiés mais beaucoup d'ouvriers
étrangers qui travaillent sur contrats
en province touchent des sommes chez les
entrepreneurs qui varie entre 3 à trois
fronts 350 un ouvrier français ne
travaillent jamais en dessous de 5
francs pour faire le même travail et il
en perd veut monter à paris où il
gagnerait peut-être un peu plus et où la
vie et beaucoup de poussière qui vivent
dans des baraquements en bois et manche
en tenant leur manger sur un feu de bois
par terre et ils ont très peu de frais
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas te permettre
mieux les problèmes peuvent se poser
entre ouvriers au moment du chômage
est ce que vous croyez que ceux des
français peuvent s'en vouloir à les
étrangers de prendre tout le travail que
pourrait faire
et bien il y en a quelques uns c'est
probablement des gens qui se laissent
conduire par des impulsions et je pense
qu'ils sont très peu nombreux il est
déjà entendu des ouvriers protester
comme quoi il y avait des étrangers que
ne trouvait pas de travail mais quand on
leur expliquait qu' on pouvait donner le
travail tout le monde en organisant les
choses un peu mieux qu'elles le sont
actuellement
et bien qu à ce moment là les gens et
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils ne disent plus
rien quoi puis-je plus de mal des
étrangers à son mandant carlos portugais
29 ans il est l'exemple de cette frange
que constituent les ouvriers étrangers
professionnellement formés mais qui se
heurte encore à des obstacles les en
france depuis quand depuis le mois
d'août 67
vous êtes arrivé comment on porte quel
moyen six arrivées par an
[Musique]
ce mur est le passeport toristes jeu
magie me suis installé d'abord en
quartier latin à paris
c'est ce que vous avez eu des problèmes
oui un peu on cherchait toujours un
maintenant chambre d'hôtel mais chercher
de l'apei en moi ou work and then loi
repris jura semaines pour que ça
devenait plus haut plus ou moins cher
alors qu'il ya eu une histoire avec une
dame de l'auteur qui nous avait lui déjà
la chambre dans laquelle vous nous
pouvions faire la cuisine
c'était très beau parce qu'ils
refusaient d'économies vous ne pouvez
pas dépenser mais si tous qu'elle a su
que nous étions des portugais on nous a
refusé la chambre l'a pas fou du puy
mois et demi après j'ai trouvé on en
trouvait à priori une chambre à pas cher
je n'ai pas trouvé de travail jusqu à un
moment j'ai trouvé un
l'ami portugais qui m'a dit qu'il y
avait un patron ici à cher ici à sa mort
qui pouvait me faire notre travail va
c'était contre hier la patronne
je suis venu il m'a donné le logement
ils n'ont fait un tout petit peu puisque
je ne trouvais ps gagnent deux fois par
semaine oui mais voilà chemin
il était très gentil parce que non
vraiment je ne travaillais pas pour lui
et un mois et demi après avoir avoir
faire là qu'à travail là sa mort j'ai
trouvé ici le travail dans la gto
ensuite entre femmes venues vivre avec
vous en france elle pouvait on sentait
qu'on prépare à vivre loin dans l'autre
donc je suis tout seul c'était pour
enfin de préparer un peu le chemin pour
la ville quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez
rester vivre en france où le travail que
j'ai fait un franc cela n'est pas bien
le travail et je suis prêt à faire et
j'aime faire partir j'étais mécanicien
d'aviation
j'étais en afrique aussi au service
d'autres des avions de la france et à
produire hier en france j'ai jamais
réussi à avoir un emploi dans les
oeuvres dans les usines d'aviation se
pose un problème donné que j'ai fait un
travail qui ne voulait pas aller mais si
vous trouvez un travail qui vous plaît
vous resterez en france oui si tout
changer au portugal que feriez vous
savez il faut préférer vivre par ce
biais de change est à vivre si je
trouvais en france un portugal ce que je
suis j'ai déjà trouvé en france c'est à
dire
et avec avec un blues le travail que
j'aimerais alors là j'allais être encore
mieux se former et se défendre et
défendre si ses compatriotes c'est à
dire un nouveau prolétariat carlos a
décidé de se syndiquer militaire afin de
comprendre le monde où il vit
aujourd'hui la passion de côté pour
pouvoir vivre cette saga nique
mais oui bien sûr bien sûr surtout que
évidemment il ya quand même se souvient
que l'année dernière et ils vivent
maintenant la fin du mois il pense que
c'est un grand un mois ils ont peur ils
ont eu ce vrai il faut reconnaître qu'il
ya des gars qui s'appelle heures et on
les comprend les peurs et surtout les
immigrés n'ont pas l'habitude de
connaissances qui ont tout de même peur
des fois pour des grès maintenant elle
habite au carré
connaître déjà de la force et ils ont et
femmes déjà qu'ils font une brève c'est
quand même parce qu'ils ont quelque
chose à revendiquer quelque chose qui me
battre il faut quand même faire avec la
force de jouer maintenant vous êtes un
militant syndicaliste pourquoi si de
méditation et réaliste ça j'avais eu le
désir a précisé que même des fois on
trouve des chiffres ou quelque chose qui
ne compte pas digéré je ne connaissais
pas tellement les syndicats français je
connaissais un petit pour la cfdt de la
cgt sud et fo mais disons que les
leviers politiques comme je n'avais pas
la liberté les avoirs éventuels la fin
j'étais toujours prêt mais on avait
parlé vers la sauce prat suspens alors
j'ai trouvé un copain de la cct qui
travaillent ici encore avec moi c'est
lui le chef de la section syndicale et
on a commencé le travail syndicat de
l'entreprise et on avait vraiment besoin
ils ont quand même leur trajet ils ont
quand même comment dirais-je ils ont
leurs princes ils ont tout un tas de
choses nous les gars contre un con qu'on
travaille en habit de champigny et qu'on
travaille champigny bain pour nous ça
nous est égal que ça on l'avait noté
combien 10o est financé sur ospina et
[Musique]